I
this individuality therefore directs its
energies to getting rid of this
necessity which contradicts the law of
the heart and also the suffering caused
by it and so it is no longer
characterized by the levity of the
previous form of self-consciousness
which only wanted the particular
pleasure of the individual on the
contrary it is the earnestness of a high
purpose which seeks its pleasure and
displaying the excellence of its own
nature and in promoting the welfare of
mankind what it realizes is itself the
law and it's pleasure is therefore at
the same time the universal pleasure of
all hearts too at the to our undivided
it's pleasure is what conforms to the
law and the realization of the law of
universal humanity procures for in its
own particular pleasure for within its
own self individuality in this the
necessary are immediately one the law is
the law of the heart individuality is
not as yet dislodged from its seat and
the unity of both has not been brought
about by the mediating agency of the
individuality itself has not been
achieved by discipline the realization
of the immediate undisciplined nature
passes for a display of its excellence
and as productive of the welfare of
humanity
there is so much that is going on here
in paragraph 370 that I couldn't put all
of it on the board but I do have the
main schema we could say for where we're
going to put all of this content and not
only is there a lot going on on the
surface there is so much that is it sort
of spills out of this in terms of
application to common examples not only
from Hagel's time but going all the way
up to the present in our own time this
is clearly a dialectic that is repeated
over and over again throughout the ages
and remember this is a particularly
modern dialectic as well and I actually
want to begin the commentary on this
passage that was the beginning of it but
the very end of it why because he talks
about a kind of naivety that's happening
here and this is important to remember
following up from the previous paragraph
369 where Hagel talked about the person
who is is trying to live out and
actualize the law of the heart as having
lost sight of the origin of this
particular shape of consciousness they
they don't realize that it actually
comes out of pleasure and now the Hagel
is going to start talking more about
pleasure and how it you know it secretly
gets itself back in here so he says
individuality is not as yet dislodged
from its seat this towards the end and
the unity of both what is the both here
individuality and the necessary has not
been brought about by the mediating
agency of the individuality itself has
not been achieved by discipline that is
it has not been achieved by a process in
which the the individuality works upon
itself it thinks that it can immediately
turn to the world and work upon the
world and change it for the better in
ways that we're going to talk about it
doesn't realize that in order
do that you require certain discipline
and so you know we it might be worth
meditating on a few examples of this
sort of thing so let's take you know the
Savior in romantic situations right
somebody is going to fix the world for
suffering humanity or at least a tiny
portion of it by making this one other
person's life better right because they
see them and they see that they're kind
of a tortured soul or perhaps they're
down on their luck and and they get the
short end of the stick even though they
deserve better they're the proverbial
diamond in the rough and you know you
fall in love with them we have lots of
romantic comedies where this happens
right you know you you see the person
struggling and and you see that they're
a decent person you want to help them
out right and where the romantic
comedies will have a little bit you know
because the the character arc is usually
interesting encounter get involved then
there has to be some sort of situation
like you kick a puppy or you know you
cheat at work or or somebody you know
says something and it's taken to the
wrong context and then they're a bad
person then they learn from their
mistake and they're there with the boom
box or the flowers or whatever right you
pick there's a million different
variations on this this same story right
and then there's a reconciliation at the
end and they're older and wiser but yet
happy together and cut two credits well
that's not the way real life works right
i mean romantic comedies are imaginary
processes instead what often happens is
the person launches into this i'm going
to save this other person through my
love right and what happens is because
there's no discipline on this side they
get in over their heads and pretty soon
they're the one who needs to be saved or
they find themselves unable to follow
through on things and you know excuses
start flying and pretty soon at all it
all falls apart
another great example would be I'm going
to help the poor because I'm i'm going
to show solidarity by living with them
hey you don't spend some time in
impoverished areas if you're not from
those kind of areas and you'll see why
people want to get the hell out of them
quite quite frankly fairly quickly and
if you you know if you approach that
sort of situation and you actually have
some discipline you know you have
developed it through I don't know mental
training or some sort of education or
something along those lines now you
actually have something to offer to
those people and that discipline
typically extends the things like how
you structure your day it can't just all
be sentimentality and wanting to be a
helper and wanting to fix things or
you're going to end up foundering and so
higgles talking about that here he says
you know there hasn't been a mediating
agency of the individual itself has not
been achieved by discipline so he says
the realization of the immediate
undisciplined nature why are people
engaging in this now here's where we get
to the hidden motives we have all these
as Hagel says fine sentiments what's
really going on says the realization of
the immediate undisciplined nature
passes for a display of its excellence
and as productive of the welfare of
humanity isn't it nice how two things
can come together you're helping
humanity or the world or the environment
or this one person or you know animals
or pick whatever you like right you're
being a helper you're making things
better you're you know every day the
world is slightly better because of your
efforts and you get to eat your cake as
well even though you're giving your cake
away I'm mixing some metaphors here but
you get the idea because you get to feel
so good about what a well person you are
for the contribution that you're making
you notice that I've got pleasure here
sort of welling up and that's Hagel
thanks that's
large part of what is going on in terms
of the law of the heart it's not just
that somebody is this absolutely
tortured soul and they have to help out
because if they don't they're going to
be miserable but they never get any
happiness out of it no it makes them
feel good and they can actually get a
little addicted to that feeling good and
sticking it pointing in the wrong way
speaking it to the man sticking it to
the power structure sticking it to the
establishment sticking it to the people
who are standing in the way it doesn't
always have to be you know done in that
sort of sense either it could be
sticking it to the Warlord's sticking it
to the criminals you could be all sorts
of variants of this this sort of thing
the patriarchy the you know the
emasculating culture whatever you like
right the point is in this shape of
consciousness the law of the heart is
connected with a kind of pleasure so
let's see how this plays out says this
individuality directs its energies to
getting rid of this necessity which
contradicts the law of the heart what's
the necessity this alien necessity that
we talked about in the last place this
unjust unfair irrational whatever we
want to say ordering or na in German of
the real world of veer click cut of what
is actual you know the office that
you're in why why do we do the
procedures this way why why do we have
the rules that we have why are those
people in charge and not people who are
you know better suited to their jobs or
care more about the employees or aren't
corrupt or or or or we can go on and on
with that sort of thing there is
something that confronts us as being
unfair unjust but the way it is so the
law of the heart says fight that get rid
of them why because then you're the good
guy or the good girl you are helping
suffering humanity now remember from the
last paragraph this is a suffering
humanity that can't truly help itself
because this alien necessity the world
order
in a certain sense contaminated it the
person who has a law of the heart is
coming in as the the you know White
Knight and he or she is going to open up
their eyes raise their class
consciousness woke them whatever you
want to put right all of these things
are variants on one big themes suffering
humanity can't take care of itself as
individuals because it's been so damaged
by the unjust whatever it happens to be
the world order so you're going to
promote their welfare as self
consciousness so he says it you know
it's no longer characterized by the
levity of the previous form of self
consciousness which only wanted the
particular pleasure of the individual
you know once you get past your own
pleasure and you say I don't need to buy
myself chocolate bars or go to the bar
or a dress in nice clothes or have the
car or whatever you know I don't need to
do all of that stuff I don't need to go
to the parties I have something more
valuable to what I'm doing I'm promoting
humanity I am fixing the world well
there's a different kind of pleasure
that comes with that but it is still
pleasure Hagel says for a lot of people
at this stage he's not saying that every
person who's a philanthropist or you
know doing charitable works or anything
like that in the world fits into this by
the way this is this is a particular
shape of consciousness but it is one
that we can identify in many examples in
our own life perhaps even in ourselves
so I says this is not the particular
pleasure of the individual on the
contrary it's the earnestness of a high
purpose which seeks its pleasure in
displaying the excellence of its own
nature so what's really happening here
in promoting the welfare of humanity in
fighting against fighting the power that
that'd be right it's also getting to
tell itself what a great guy it is or a
great gal it is
is because it's doing these wonderful
things it has a high purpose I'm not
just you know kicking in these doors or
you know scrawling things or leaving
comments on an Internet video because I
just you know like to screw with people
or I'm you know having some fun or
anything like that I'm doing something
real I'm opposing badness and I'm
helping people that's a high purpose
that's what Hagel's talking about here
that's the law of the heart so he says
what it realizes is itself the law and
it's pleasure therefore at the same time
as the universal pleasure of all hearts
notice what's going on there there is an
exchange of pleasure at least an
imaginary way between the individual
self consciousness who is acting in the
world according to the law of the heart
and the humanity which is being turned
essentially into sort of a mirror or a
set of props but still also being in
hopefully respected as humanity for that
that allows now this this individual to
Center the universality of all hearts in
its individual heart at least at this
stage at least in its mind now what or
often happens in cases like this is
there is a brutal confrontation with
reality and it usually comes by the
suffering humanity actually saying oh
wow enough of your nonsense we don't
need your do-gooder attitude here
because you don't know what the hell
you're doing and sometimes you're
actually making things worse and you
seem to be more interested in your high
purpose and how you look them in our
actual welfare as we understand that but
that pushback is going to happen later
on right now the individual self
conscious
gets to bask in its effectiveness in its
high purpose in you know what great
things that is doing how it's promoting
humanity gets to feel a kind of unity
which it's projecting imaginatively all
of that is contained in this paragraph
all of that I think is highly relevant
not only its understanding human actions
from Hagel's time and even before it
onward to our own but in our present so
where do we go from here that's what we
have to see is this going to work out or
is this going to fall apart
the law on the other hand which
confronts the law of the heart is
separated from the heart that exists in
its own right humanity which is bound by
this law does not live in the blasted
unity of the law with the heart but
either lives in their cruel separation
and in suffering or at least dispenses
with the enjoyment of itself you know in
obeying the law and lacks the
consciousness of its own excellence in
transgressing it because that
authoritative divine and human ordinance
is separated from the heart it is for
the latter a mere show which ought to
lose what is still associated with it
that is the power of authority and
reality in its content it may well by
chance agree with the law of the heart
and then the latter can submit to it but
for the heart what is essential is not
the bear conformity to law as such but
that in the law it has the consciousness
of itself that there in it has satisfied
itself we're however the content of
universal necessity is not agree with
the heart then necessity even as regards
its own regards its content is itself
nothing and must give way before the law
of the heart
here in paragraph 371 Hagel is deepening
and making starker this confrontation
between the individual who is motivated
by the law of the heart and the cruel
the unfair how are we going to put
irrational nepotistic you know whatever
World Order but now it's being talked
about not just in terms of ordinal that
is a structure a a way in which things
are arranged but a law suits and we have
a confrontation between two laws one
which appears to be much more effective
the one that's governing the world and
the rest of humanity then the law of the
heart is because the law of the heart so
far just applies to this this particular
individual there is something going on
here that gives a sort of impetus or
energy to the law of the heart which is
what he's going to talk about in terms
of a unity and an associated effective
reflection of that in terms of law of
the heart but he says the law on the
other hand which confronts the law of
the heart is separated from the heart
and exists in its own right it is a
alien necessity as he's called it it is
a sort of brute factum you're born into
a society what we see here again is a
sort of a recapitulation of the old you
know ethical substance but now the
ethical substances turned dark and
forbidding and mean and unfair right the
mores the laws the customs of your
society the zipa right have turned
against the law of the heart the law
that wants to set things right so he
says humanity which is bound by this law
remember that the person the
self-consciousness that's motivating the
law of the heart wants to save wants to
benefit wants to promote the welfare of
the rest of these poor suckers in
humanity who who aren't able to do that
for them
so he's humanity which is bound by this
law does not live in the Blessed unity
of the law with the heart so there is a
unity of the law and the heart in the
person who is experiencing this the rest
of humanity doesn't have that instead
what they live in he says is a cruel
separation and suffering there is a
realization on the part of humanity
there they're not totally you know out
to lunch right they're like yeah things
are screwed up but nobody has an idea
about how to fix it or the idea is that
they have just fit right back into the
World Order and perpetuate it right so
he goes on he says they live in cruel
separation and suffering or it dispenses
with the enjoyment of itself in obeying
the law a law that's worth obeying will
actually feel good if the individual is
rightly oriented towards it to obey
right so if we know that for example
when we're playing games I'll take a
very trivial example that following the
rules makes for a better and more
enjoyable game even if it means that we
lose the game and we follow the rules we
feel a kind of satisfaction in that we
call that sportsmanship right it's
reflected in a virtue so he says there's
that or it lacks the consciousness of
its own excellence in transgressing it
so when these people do transgress the
law of the World Order say through
criminality they they may take a certain
kind of pleasure am sticking it to those
guys but it's an individual pleasure
it's not a hey I'm like benefiting
humanity by transgressing these unjust
laws these unfair social arrangements
I'm actually doing something to promote
humanity there isn't any sense of that
at least that's how it appears for the
person over here who is motivated by the
law of the heart so he says because that
authoritative divine and human ordinance
is separated from the heart it is for
the law of the heart a mere show a shine
an appearance right
it's not the reality of things doesn't
have real effectiveness to it that's
what emboldened the person of the law of
the heart to get in there and start
mixing it up so that person also thinks
that the law or the order the way of the
world ought to lose these things that it
actually he says that it has Authority
gevalt the the sense of this is not you
know like legitimate Authority it's like
is what's been imposed and reality veer
CLE cut its reality a lot to be
abolished if there are unfair social
arrangements say that some people don't
get to go to school or participate in
certain jobs because of you know one
qualification or another like say the
color of their skin well we get rid of
that we make that no longer a reality or
we make it if it is a reality just
something that's being transgressive and
criminal right so you know this there
are in fact all sorts of unfair unjust
inequitably irrational power structures
in societies and so the law of the heart
person is reacting against that hinkle
goes on and he says here we go in its
content it may well by chance agree with
the law of the heart and then the latter
can submit to it so sometimes even in a
the most unfair society there will be
some things like there may be a law
against stealing right so you follow
that law even though by not stealing
you're still supporting the power
structure well it's still not stealing
and so you can feel okay about that but
he says but for the heart what is
essential is not the bear conformity to
law as such but that in the Lord has the
consciousness of itself that there in it
has satisfied itself that it can say
yeah I buy into this I ratify this I can
legislate this for myself
for all humanity as a reasonable rule
does that sound like anybody by the way
now we're actually starting to get
closer to the con sheehan kingdom of
ends aren't we and there's some
overtones there although remember this
is in terms of sentiment not in terms of
principle right and there are a lot of
people trying to push something like
that in hegel's time we can just get
people to feel the right way and then
the right ideas will come forth from
that you know today we talk in terms of
hey if we could just get people to be
empathetic if they were empathetic then
we would naturally understand the plight
of the other and we wouldn't other them
and we wouldn't you know you know let
power and principalities and the
political system do what it does to them
and haga lo said well we got to be
careful with that you know maybe you're
putting a little bit too much stock in
the power of empathy to deliver
something greater than itself which
would be principles which would be
something that could be objective not
just a feeling that you have Hagel is
always going to be telling us that
feelings are not by themselves a good
guide so he goes on and he says we're
however the content of universal
necessity is not agree with the heart
the necessity even as regards as content
is in itself nothing and must give way
before the law of the heart this is in
part why the law of the heart and the
single individual can have a in some
cases world-shaking effectivity a way of
changing things because they can
actually say I understand that you've
got this entire system over here and
that it's necessary but I don't care
about your necessity because I have
something higher than that that I can
oppose to it you think you got necessity
I got real vital Ness
the he might be staying and so that is
what the individual is going to do this
is very powerful this leads to social
transformations at times but there is
also a dynamic that is self-defeating
within it that now we're going to
explore
you